leider auch schon eine vielzahl von
opfern zu beklagen hatten
was er erreicht haben das ist ein
zwischenerfolg
nicht mehr und nicht weniger und ich
betone es ist ein zerbrechlicher
zwischenerfolg das hat herr wieder vom
robert-koch-institut uns heute noch
einmal gesagt wir haben die faktoren die
dafür einen aussage treffen in eine gute
richtung entwickelt aber wir haben auch
nicht viel spielraum sondern wir müssen
jetzt ganz konzentriert weitermachen
deshalb hat unsere beratungen bestimmt
das ist jetzt kein falsches vorpreschen
geben darf auch wenn die besten
absichten dahinter stehen sondern wir
müssen verstehen dass wir so lange mit
dem virus leben müssen wie es keine
medikamente und insbesondere keinen
impfstoff gibt und wir müssen die
erfolge sichern die wir erreicht haben
und deshalb ist es sozusagen wenn wir
darüber sprechen welche schritte in
richtung einer eines etwas mehr zulassen
von öffentlichen leben die wir ja alle
gehen wollen wir gehen dann müssen wir
sagen es ist geht um äußerste vorsicht
die arbeiten lassen müssen und das hat
unsere beratungen heute auch geprägt
denn es geht jedes mal um menschen
wir haben uns geeinigt dass wir
natürlich ausgehend von unseren
beschlüssen die wir am 12
16 und 22 märz 2020 gefasst haben und
dass es auch weiter entscheidend bleibt
dass bürgerinnen und bürger in der
öffentlichkeit ein mindestabstand von
1,5 metern einhalten und sich dort nur
alleine mit einer weiteren nicht im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im an
kreis der angehörigen des eigenen
hausstandes aufhalten
das gilt weiterhin und die verstöße
dagegen werden auch weiter von den
ordnungsbehörden geahndet um zukünftig
infektionsketten schnell zu erkennen ist
mir etwas ganz wichtig und ich bedanke
mich bei den ländern die auch zum großen
teil ihre gesundheitsbehörden schon
aufgestockt haben wenn wir jetzt mehr
öffentliches leben zu lassen
in kleinen schritten dann ist es ganz
wichtig dass wir noch besser die
infektionsketten verfolgen können es
muss unser ziel sein jede
infektionskette verfolgen zu können
dafür werden wir arbeiten wir auch an
einer app aber vor allen dingen ist es
die aufgabe der gesundheitsbehörden
denn wenn wir das können dann können wir
auch infektionsherde eingrenzen und dann
ist die leckere lockerung im bereich des
öffentlichen lebens nicht mehr so
gravierend weil wir ja wissen wo
entstehen infektionsherd wenn wir das
nicht haben dann werden wir nicht so
erfolgreich sein und deshalb ist das von
ganz ganz entscheidender bedeutung
wir wollen natürlich eine gute
versorgung mit test kapazitäten wir
wollen an der medizinischen
schutzausrüstung arbeiten die haben wir
sehr ausführlich über die frage der
sogenannten alltags masken gesprochen
und sprechen uns dafür aus dass es
empfehlenswert ist dass es geboten ist
sozusagen diese alltags masken auch zu
verwenden im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und in beim einkaufen
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger punkt
der jetzt auch weiterentwickelt wurde in
unseren beschlüssen wir werden also den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die nutzung
entsprechender alltags masten
insbesondere im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und beim einkauf
dringend empfehlen wir glauben dass wir
in mit jedem tag jetzt mehr diese
alltags masken bekommen werden und dass
das dann auch dazu dienen sollte andere
menschen zu schützen und wenn es viele
tun dann eben auch sich selbst zu
schützen
wir haben immer pflegeheime gesprochen
hier wird es ganz wichtig sein dass wir
uns altenheime dass wir individuelle
konzepte entwickeln um nicht die soziale
isolation der menschen in diesen heimen
zu haben und trotzdem die
sicherheitsstandards einzuhalten
und wir haben natürlich eine
ausführliche diskussion über
kindergärten schulen und hochschulen
geführt und ich weiß wie viele menschen
in deutschland gerade diese diskussion
verfolgen denn das ist natürlich eine
ganz ganz schwierige situation für
eltern dass ihre kinder nicht
andere freunde treffen können dass es
nur eine notbetreuung gibt dass die
allermeisten zu hause sind und trotzdem
müssen wir um die anforderungen auch an
den infektionsschutz einzuhalten und
menschenleben zu sichern wir ganz
behutsam ganz schrittweise vorgehen
das ist uns heute auch gelungen indem
wir uns vor allen dingen erst einmal auf
die abschlussklassen die prüfung machen
müssen konzentrieren
in einem nächsten schritt auf die dann
prüfung machen oder schulwechsel vor
sich haben und dass die
kultusministerkonferenz uns dann nochmal
ein ausführliches konzept vorlegt
genauso wie die jugend ministerkonferenz
denn wir können nur schrittweise dann
nach dem 4
langsam wieder die einzelnen schulen
dinge machen es muss in reduzierten
gruppen seien es muss ein schulbus
konzept da sein es muss ein pausen
konzept da sein es wird also ein hoher
logistischer aufwand zu betreiben seien
und deshalb bedarf es einer intensiven
vorbereitung und ich weiß wie viel
verzicht das noch für eltern bedeutet
aber ich glaube es ist einfach notwendig
wenn wir sagen wir müssen in der
pandemie mit diesem virus leben und das
deutet sich dort auch an der betriebe
müssen auch hygiene konzepte anfertigen
und werden dann am vierten mai ihre
arbeit wieder aufnehmen können wenn die
schutzmaßnahmen ausreichend sind wir
haben intensiv über das hohe gut der
religionsfreiheit gesprochen und auch
über die veranstaltungen die natürlich
bei den von den kirchen stattfinden ich
möchte den kirchen ein ganz herzliches
dankeschön sagen denn sie haben gerade
jetzt über ostern viel phantasie
bewiesen dass obwohl keine gottesdienste
stattfinden konnten menschen auch ihren
glauben leben konnten wir wollen dass
religiöse feierlichkeiten
veranstaltungen und zusammenkünfte
anderer glaubensgemeinschaften zunächst
weiter nicht stattfinden aber es wird
noch in dieser woche ein gespräch von
ministerpräsidenten und dem
bundesministerium des innern geben über
die frage wie man einen einvernehmlichen
weg für das weitere vorgehen findet
wichtig ist dass wir das wirtschaftliche
die wirtschaftliche tätigkeit im großen
ganzen ja nicht unterbunden
sondern nur dort wo es publikumsverkehr
gibt hier haben wir uns natürlich sehr
ausführlich mit der frage der eröffnung
weiterer geschäfte fast hier haben wir
auf der einen seite gesagt es können
geschäfte bis zu 800 quadratmetern auf
machen allerdings mit guten konzepten
für die nutzung dieser kunst und dieser
geschäfte mit hygiene konzepten und wir
müssen auch schauen dass nicht sozusagen
auf den straßen sich riesige schlangen
bilden auch das gehört mit zum
verantwortungsbereich und das wollen der
werden auch eine vielzahl von vorarbeit
vorbereitungsarbeiten geführt werden
müssen
wir werden viel in die forschung
investieren das ist unstrittig um gerade
auch unseren teil dazu zu leisten noch
mehr zu erforschen was wie viele
menschen hatten diese infektion schon
was wir können wir beitragen zu einem
impfstoff entwicklung welche medikamente
sind wichtig und ich darf sagen dass wir
auch gerade seitens des bundesheer ein
sehr großzügiger finanzieller
unterstützung alles tun damit der
forschungsstandort deutschland auch
seinen beitrag zur bewältigung dieser
pandemie leisten kann abschließend
wir werden uns immerhin 14 tages
abstimmen mit dem weiteren entwicklungen
befassen wir wollen sehen welche
auswirkungen haben die lockerungs
möglichkeiten die wir heute ins auge
gefasst haben auf die entwicklung der
infektion und in diesem sinne ist es uns
deshalb werden wir uns deshalb abend 30
april wieder darüber unterhalten was
passiert dann nach dem dritten mai die
spanne die wir jetzt ins auge gefasst
haben ist sie zwischen dem 20 april und
den dritten und dann werden wir in
weiteren schritten vorgehen und das wird
jetzt ganz davon abhängen wie entwickeln
sich die infektionsraten ich sagte schon
wir haben da nicht viele spielräume und
deshalb hoffe ich dass alle weiter so
mitmachen und die regeln einhalten das
alles ermöglicht uns dann ein kleines
stück immer weiter öffentliches leben
wie wir es gewohnt sind aber eben in der
pandemie
das heißt anders und mit anderen regeln
ja wenn ich so herr söder
ich habe heute sehr geehrte damen und
herren vor bundeskanzler erst mal ich
glaube das wort eine sehr sehr gute sehr
wichtig und sehr verantwortungsbewusste
diskussion die wir geführt haben
die war geprägt von dem tiefen
bewusstsein baby unser land und die
menschen weiter schützen können
eines kann man glaube ich sagen
deutschland ist bislang im vergleich zu
vielen anderen ländern besser durch
diese schlimme krise die global
stattfindet gekommen
wir können schon sagen dass wir corona
zumindest anders unter kontrolle haben
als in vielen anderen ländern der welt
warum weil die strategie die wir
entwickelt haben die richtige war
rechtzeitig frühzeitig zu handeln und
konsequent zu bleiben
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir diesen
grundlegenden weg fortsetzen
ich freue mich heute dass wir weiter
einen vorsichtigen weg beschritten haben
wir haben keine unkontrollierten exit
strategien diskutiert sondern wir setzen
weiter auf vorsicht auch vorsicht denn
wir glauben dass die größte gefahr
bestehen könnte dass die guten zahlen
das heißt guten zahlen also die
entwicklung die stabil ist dass die
einen rückschlag erleidet wenn wir zu
viel riskieren wenn wir leichtsinnig
werden und wenn wir normalität
vortäuschen dies noch nicht geben kann
solange es keinen impfstoff solange es
keine medikamente gibt solange müssen
wir einen weg an konzept finden mit
corona zu leben in form von so viel
sicherheit wie möglich aber auch den
möglichkeiten der freiheit den menschen
wieder zu geben
vor dem hintergrund haben wir die
unterschiedlichsten bereiche diskutiert
miteinander gewogen wir an spielräume
entwickelt war natürlich länder
unterschiedlich betroffen sind
das süden deutschland sich stärker
betroffen mit infektion als andere teile
von deutschlands insofern haben wir auch
rahmen definiert die unterschiedlich
ausgeschöpft werden können
beispielsweise für mein land kann ich
sagen wir werden das vorsichtiger
angehen und etwas zurückhaltend angehen
aber die möglichkeiten sind auch je nach
der infektion lage stärker zu gewichten
wichtig ist vorsicht besonnenheit ist an
der stelle wichtig als überstürztes
vorgehen was uns in einigen wochen zu
einem ergebnis führen könne
dass die zahlen sie schlechter
entwickeln und wir dann zurück drehen
müssen denn über eines darf sich keiner
täuschen
die gute entwicklung hängt mit den
maßnahmen zusammen die getroffen worden
auch länder die anfangs anders gedacht
haben sind letztlich den weg den
deutschland geht nahezu vollständig
gefolgt einige später einige unter
schmerzen dass wir glaube ich sollte in
deutschland nicht vergessen dass es ganz
anders aussehen könnte hätten wir falsch
zu spät oder nicht umsichtig reagiert
wir wollen uns jetzt nicht durch die
gegend tasten sondern wollen mit
versuchen mit weitblick und übersicht
durch diese weitere krise zu führen
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir in
schritten arbeiten und schauen wie die
schritte würden nicht nur was die
schritte an normalität bedeuten sondern
vor allem was bedeuten die schritte auch
in der entwicklung der infektionen und
deswegen nicht alles auf einmal sondern
abgestuft zeitversetzt bestimmte
bereiche einfacher bestimmte bereiche
deutlich zurückhaltender
die philosophie muss lauten fortsetzen
das strategie erleichtern womöglich ist
das aber mit schutz versehen jeder
leistung mit schutz versehen und wichtig
die vorsorge intensiv ausbauen aufbauen
das ist das erste und vielleicht auch
nach wie vor die wichtigste botschaft
die distanz gebot ausgangs
beschränkungen oder kontakt dann wie
immer man es kennt die bleiben erhalten
geschäfte werden leicht und schrittweise
geöffnet aber mit schutzkonzepte
schutzkonzepte heißen infektions
schützende bereiche zu machen best
infektionen abstand zu halten
auch bestimmte 2020 auf 20 quadratmeter
eine person zu nehmen
und deswegen genau den bereich auf der
masken in den vordergrund zu rücken
für uns ist klar der staat sorgt was die
masten struktur betrifft für
medizinische masten um im pflege in
altenheimen in krankenhäusern und ärzten
die hochwertigen ganz besonders auch
schwierig herzustellen masken
sicherzustellen
das ist aufgabe des staates aber bei
geschäften und im privaten und im pv
bereich ist es wichtig dass man auch mit
einfachen community masken mit einem
entsprechenden mund und nasenschutz
entsprechend auch selbstständig
deswegen ja bei geschäften gibt es eine
eine leichte hoffnung wir im süden
das war etwas zeitversetzt machen aber
es gibt diese öffnung bis maximal 800
quadratmeter auch da ist unterschiedlich
wäre das ausschöpfen
es muss eben der jeweiligen struktur
entsprechend auch verantwortet werden
ich halte es aber für richtig dass wir
diese form machen aber immer noch einmal
mit der hygiene konzept deswegen kann
man das auch nicht gleich machen war
gerade kleinere geschäfte brauchen ein
stückweit seite um die umsetzung zu
machen auch da gilt der grundsatz
langsamer bringt mehr erfolg als
hektisch und überstürzt auch für die
wirtschaft klar ist dass gastronomie
hotel für tourismus bars diskurs
kaufhäuser shopping malls also alles das
wo sich enorm viele menschen ansammeln
nach wie vor nicht geöffnet werden
können
wir werden den nächsten wochen dann
entscheiden aber dass wir zurückhaltend
sind können sie daran sehen dass wir
großveranstaltungen bis ende august
bereits klar gesagt haben das geht nicht
also alles was an bierfest man
großveranstaltungen ist werden auf
keinen fall stattfinden können denn bis
dahin haben wir weder medikamente noch
im stoff und wir haben gesehen dass der
abriss in israel dass der karneval in
heinsberg oder stark wir bei unseren
tirschenreuth das waren ja leider
plattformen in der eine starke und auch
schlimme ausbreitung möglich gewesen
deswegen da große zurückhaltung was die
glaubensgemeinschaft mit spd
bundeskanzlers zu recht gesagt wir
schätzen dass guter glaubensfreiheit
enorm und es hat jeden geschmack ist an
ostern zu sehen
bewundernswert übrigens auch
beispielsweise wieder der heilige vater
papst diese messe auch in einem sehr
stark gebeutelt wie in italien das ganze
gemacht hat da wird über konzepte
nachgedacht wie wir das vernünftig
miteinander machen können zu schulen
bei schulen da sind wir uns einig und da
bin ich sehr sehr dankbar dass wir da
keine falschen entscheidung getroffen
haben und wie ab nächster woche alles
öffnen denn auch unsere lehrerverbände
den ich an der stelle ein großes
dankeschön sagen möchte klären
lehrerverbände in deutschland machen
sich wirklich gute gedanken wie wir den
schulbetrieb klug machen können auch die
kmk arbeitet bereits so war für uns ist
wichtig dass er für die länder ganz
entscheidend weil sie auch
unterschiedliche zeit zyklen mit abitur
prüfungen mit ferien
zunächst mal dass man die vorbereitung
trifft das die abiturprüfungen
beispielsweise oder mittlere reife oder
quali stattfinden können das ist der
erste schritt dann erst mit einer zeit
versetzt hat das ist dann ab 11 den mai
würden wir sind bayern machen ab vierten
mal ins andere dann über
abschlussklassen zu reden und andere
dinge die grundschule kita bleiben
vorerst allerdings versehen mit
notfallbetreuung auszuweiten
denn wenn wir bestimmte geschäfte öffnen
brauchen wir ja auch eine entsprechende
bessere betreuung da haben sich die
länder verpflichtet das an der stelle zu
machen und die kultusminister müssen
sich dann mit den fragen noch einmal
beschäftigen wie wir bei mehr schülern
in der schule das zu organisieren dass
abstand gehalten werden kann
welche fächer unterrichtet werden müssen
wie man auch mit versetzungen umgeht was
ganz wichtig ist denn vielen schülern
viel zeit um sozusagen in der kritischen
phase eine versetzung zu schaffen
andere wären froh wenn es dann schon zu
ende gewesen mit dem schuljahr
es müsse man sehr klug überlegen da
brauchen wir sehr seriöse konzepte damit
die für alle mittel treten können
aber noch mal wichtig bei grundschulen
und kitas bleiben vorerst dies auf das
der denkbar vierte klasse also übertritt
bleiben erst einmal geschlossen
wir glauben einfach dass man auch den
kleinen kindern nicht zumuten kann
mit mundschutz und ähnlichem zu leben
oder zu arbeiten und da ist es auch sehr
schwer zu appellieren jetzt zu sagen
verhaltet euch mal entsprechend so wie
ich schon manche erwachsene sich schwer
tun was das thema mundschutz betrifft
geht natürlich übrigens auch für den
öpnv
ich glaube dass wir im öpnv dass wir in
bereichen auch der geschäfte die jetzt
sich weiterentwickeln in der öffnung
dass wir da er stärker dieses masken die
brut verstehen müssen
und auch da stärker daran erinnern
müssen denn all die bereiche wo man kurz
auch zusammen ist sehr nahen oder
abstand schwerer zu halten ist da ist
eine maske da ist ein mundschutz ein
ganz einfacher übrigens und nasenschutz
ein hilfreiches instrument besondern zu
bringen
letzter punkt strategie fortsetzen
erleichterungen machen
und vorsorge verstärkt unser ziel ist ja
wenn es optimal lief in so einer phase
die bei webasto zu kommen dass wir die
einzelfällen infektionsketten gut
verfolgen konnten das drama in italien
war ja dass infektionsketten nicht mehr
verfolgbar waren und damit völlig
unkontrollierte ausbreitung da war das
gelingt uns aber nur wenn wir neben der
erhöhung der intensivbetten weiter und
ich glaube man kann jetzt eigentlich
sagen das deutsche gesundheitssystem
bei aller kritik die es immer geht hat
den internationalen bewährungstest im
moment gut bestanden das kann man
wirklich sagen und wir gehen eher höher
wir sagen wir wollen eher mehr machen
wir brauchen mehr in den städten mehr
medizinische versorgung
wir brauchen ganz wichtig mehr test
kapazitäten die müssen wir deutlich
ausweiten
bei uns beispielsweise wir testen
wirklich sehr sehr viel und wir wollen
die test kapazitäten noch einmal massiv
ausbauen
weil nur über tests wir die gesamte
datenlage und auch die verfolgung von
infektionsketten gewinnen können und
last not least wir brauchen auch den
ausbau der gesundheitsämter bei uns wenn
es 4000 personen sein die wir zusätzlich
bilden also insgesamt 650 teams allein
in bayern die die jeweilige
rückverfolgung und auch beobachtung und
entsprechende beachtung der
infektionskette machen können fazit ich
bin im bund sehr dankbar der bund hat
heute auch sehr mitgeholfen dass auch
aus unterschiedlichen positionen der
länder am ende ein gemeinschaftlicher
geist weiter herrscht das ist glaube ich
ganz wichtig also deutschland hat eine
gemeinschaftliche philosophie und auch
die debatten der letzten tage glaube ich
sind jetzt heute in ein gutes ergebnis
gemündet es verlässlichkeit
vergleichbarkeit und großen ganzen sehr
einheitlicher rahmen
in ganz deutschland gibt es gab schon
ein paar kleine unterschiede die sind
aber nicht schlimm die bleiben auch mal
eine woche hin oder her aber im großen
und ganzen sind alle länder sich mit dem
bund komplett einig in der strategie und
die strategie heißt vorsicht heißt wir
sind noch nicht über den berg aber wenn
wir diese geduld die wir haben weiter
klug umsetzen dann glaube ich werden wir
am ende vielleicht sogar aus dieser
ganzen situation gestärkt hervorgehen
können als es viele viele andere länder
der welt schaffen können
vielen dank herr bürgermeister
tschentscher ja sehr geehrte damen und
herren als wir vor einigen wochen
erkannt haben dass deutschland doch sehr
stark von der korona pandemie ergriffen
wird haben die bundes- und die
landesregierung ja keine vollbremsung
gemacht aber fast wir haben in sehr
kurzer zeit mit sehr geringen zeitlichen
und inhaltlichen unterschieden
das öffentliche leben weitgehend
zurückgefahren
wir haben die öffentliche bewegungen
eingeschränkt wir haben alles gemacht
was wir unbedingt machen mussten um uns
überhaupt zu orientieren und sicheren
boden unter die füße zu bekommen in
dieser doch sehr schwierigen situation
wo wir nicht riskieren wollten bilder
die wir aus italien aus spanien aus
frankreich vor augen hatten hier in
deutschland zu riskieren und die gute
nachricht heute ist hier haben das
infektionsgeschehen dadurch sehr sehr
stark verlangsamt die kritische
nachricht ist wir haben nicht viel
spielraum
das eis ist dünn wir müssen bei allem
was wir tun wir denken dass der erfolg
der bisherigen maßnahmen nicht in frage
gestellt wird
zugleich ist uns bewusst geworden in den
letzten wochen dass es ist wie mit luft
anhalten
die ersten zehn sekunden sind noch
leicht die nächsten zehn sekunden werden
schwieriger und nach weiteren sekunden
spürt man plötzlich wie stark auch die
folgewirkung sind die wirtschaftlichen
folgen die sozialen folgen wirkungen die
psychologischen fragen die auswirkungen
im bildungssystem und deswegen war heute
die diskussion geprägt davon dass wir an
den wichtigsten stellen die
erleichterungen jetzt von den
beschränkungen so formulieren dass wir
diese beschränkungen mit maß und im
blick auf die wirkung sehr sehr dosiert
lockern
und immer wenn so der impuls war von
jemandem mensch eigentlich müssten wir
doch stärker in die normalität zurück
man war immer dieses verantwortungsvolle
im hintergrund das könnte ein zu großer
schritt sein wir dürfen nicht in
einzelnen bereichen zu viel riskieren
und damit den gesamterfolg infrage
stellen und in dieser doch wirklich ganz
gemeinsamen haltung sind wir durch die
themen durch die maßnahmenpakete
gegangen die vorbereitet sind
und haben wir wirklich einen
verantwortungsvollen einen maßvollen
schritt jetzt vereinbart
einerseits mit weiteren mit
erleichterungen die jetzt auch nötig
sind und die maßvoll sind andererseits
aber auch mit maßnahmen die vereinbart
werden um das infektionsgeschehen noch
besser in den griff zu bekommen
die korona test kapazitäten sollen
vergrößert werden das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen muss gestärkt werden
die das tracing von von kontakten soll
ausgearbeitet werden
wir müssen uns über einen längeren
zeitraum in dieser situation darauf
einstellen dass wir mit der pandemie zu
tun haben
auch das ist eine klare botschaft heute
der gesundheits experten des
robert-koch-instituts wir werden über
monate noch mit solchen einschränkungen
leben müssen und deswegen müssen wir
auch prüfen wie wir am besten durch
diese schwierigen monate kommen und das
was heute vereinbart ist wir sind die
wichtigsten maßnahmen die wir jetzt
umsetzen wollen
wir werden das kontrollieren es muss
über die nächsten monate immer wieder
nötig seien und und wichtig wird es sein
dass wir kontrollieren wie sich die
dinge die wir tun die wir umsetzen die
vorkehrungen die wir treffen die die
sich im wirklichen infektionsgeschehen
auswirken denn es bleibt nach wie vor
das oberste ziel das wir gesundheit und
menschenleben schützen unser
gesundheitssystem nicht überlasten und
damit eben etwas tun was wir wirklich
als breites bewusstsein in der
bevölkerung auch wahrnehmen dass das ein
gemeinsames ziel ist es ihr gemeinsam
unsere eigene gesundheit aber eben auch
das gemeinwesen schützen wenn wir mit
der gleichen disziplin jetzt weiter
vorangehen wie wir das in den letzten
wochen erlebt haben herr minister scholz
die welt hat sich für uns alle geändert
angesichts an der weltweiten pandemie
die alle menschen auf der welt
gleichermaßen trifft aber die länder
ganz unterschiedlich deutschland hat
große heraus möglichkeiten mit dieser
herausforderung zurechtzukommen
angesichts einer sehr starken wirtschaft
und natürlich auch eine sehr robusten
und starken sozialstaates und
möglichkeiten verschafft gerade was das
gesundheitswesen betrifft die
anderenorts nicht in gleicher weise zur
verfügung stehen aber auch für uns gilt
wenn sich alles ändert ändert sich eben
viel im leben
für diejenigen die arbeiten gehen wollen
und ihre arbeitsplätze nicht mehr wie
gewohnt wahrnehmen können für die
unternehmen die planen das mit ihrer
eigenen zukunft weiter sein wird aber
auch im alltagsleben aller bürgerinnen
und bürger die ihre freundin nicht mehr
sehen können wie bisher die viele
gewohnte veranstaltungen und
lebenspraktischen nicht mehr fortsetzen
können ich finde dass wir den bürgern
und bürger dieses landes sehr dankbar
sein können für das was sie leisten denn
die eigentliche beobachtung die wir
machen können ist doch dass es eine
großes einvernehmen gibt mit der
notwendigkeit auch drastische maßnahmen
zu ergreifen und das ist eine große coup
und besonnenheit gibt auf die wir als
diejenigen die mit einem
regierungsauftrag versehen sind auch
zählen können genauso wie die parlamente
was wir natürlich auch brauch in einer
solchen situation ist geschlossen hat es
ist deshalb sehr gut dass die regierung
in dieser frage sehr eng und gut
zusammen arbeitet und es sehr gut dass
diese geschlossenheit auch gilt im
verhältnis zwischen bund und ländern
gern wird ja geklagt oder die
beschwerlichkeiten des föderalismus ich
will die klage in die nicht einstimmen
aus meiner sicht dass es genau umgekehrt
die tatsache dass wir jetzt sehr
sorgfältig noch viele stunden nicht nur
heute sondern auch die letzten tage
diskutiert haben über das was jetzt zu
machen es und dass wir in der regierung
einen vorschlag entwickeln konnten der
dann am ende auch für alle länder
funktioniert hat ist eigentlich etwas
das dazu beiträgt dass unsere
entscheidungs vorschläge miteinander
besser werden und dass wir miteinander
das land besser regieren können was in
dieser situation ganz besonders wichtig
ist geschlossenheit ist also auch etwas
was man braucht was es aber eben gibt
und für die regierung wie für uns alle
gemeinsam gilt was wir brauchen es
augenmaß um zuversicht um in dieser
situation besonnen zu handeln und
jeweils abzuwägen was der mögliche
nächste schritt ist der die erreichten
erfolge nicht gefährdet ich glaube dass
setzt sehr viel selbstkritische
reflexionen voraus wir müssen immer
fragen hat das gestimmt was wir gemacht
haben
auch bereit sein entscheidung zu
korrigieren falls das notwendig ist und
nicht
aus falschen gründen hat etwas
festzuhalten dass sich nicht bewährt hat
aber in diesem sinne mit augenmaß und
zuversicht können wir jetzt auch
veränderungen vornehmen
die mit den beschlüssen die die
ministerpräsident und die regierung
heute gemeinsam gefasst haben auch
verbunden sind
wir öffnen stückweise ein teil des
sozialen lebens und auch der
wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit weil wir
glauben dass könnte genau das maß sein
was jetzt möglich ist ohne die erfolge
zu gefährden
und das ist ein richtiger ein wichtiger
schritt der jetzt gebraucht wird für das
worum es eigentlich geht wir bewegen uns
in eine neue normalität eine normalität
die nicht kurz sein wird sondern die
längere zeit anhalten wird bis es uns
gelungen wird bessere therapeutische
möglichkeiten zu haben und auch
impfstoffe zu besitzen die uns helfen
die ausbreitung der pandemie in
deutschland und anderenorts zu
verhindern
solange das nicht der fall ist wird es
eine lange zeit geben in der wir unsere
wirtschaftliche praxis unsere soziale
praxis so verändert haben müssen dass
wir mit dem virus und mit seinen
auswirkungen mit dem infektionsgeschehen
trotzdem ein gutes leben miteinander
haben weil das gut gelingt mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und weil sie
klug und besonnen sind weil wir alle
gemeinsam augenmaß und zuversicht haben
können wir glaube ich davon ausgehen
dass wir eine chance haben das zu
schaffen und das wäre ja nicht schlecht
weil es ja auch eine zeit danach geben
muss in der wir dann auf diese erfahrung
zurückgreifen können und eine weitere
zukunft reden können wir kommen zu ihren
fragen die erste von jörg blank von der
dpa frau bundeskanzlerin gaststätten
restaurants und hotels bleiben erstmal
geschlossen die bürger sind zu hause
geblieben weitgehend über ostern im mai
kingston
können sie da vielleicht einen
silberstreif am horizont sehen auch für
die menschen was pfingsten angeht und
muss man möglicherweise für das
gastronomie und den tourismusbereich die
hilfen noch einmal aufstocken und herr
ministerpräsident söder
eine frage können sie uns bitte erklären
warum man gerade die 800 quadratmeter
gewählt hat und nicht vielleicht 600
oder 1200 das ist ja eine wichtige frage
danke also zu der frage was passiert mit
gastronomie restaurants und ähnlichem
können wir heute noch nicht sagen wir
gehen jetzt in kleineren schritten voran
und wir müssen schauen wie sich das
auswirkt wir haben nach wie vor an die
menschen die aufforderung außerhalb des
eigenen hausstandes nur mit einer
einzigen person also ich außerhalb des
haushalts aufzuhalten und sie können
sich vielleicht vorstellen bei
gaststätten gastronomie ist es überhaupt
nicht mehr kontrollierbar wer um einen
tisch herum sitzt und deshalb müssen wir
hier schon darauf achten dass wir
sozusagen die maßstäbe nicht vollkommen
verschieben also das ist noch nicht dran
und wir müssen jetzt erst mal gucken ob
wir mit den schritten die wir jetzt
gehen öffnung anderer geschäfte
abschlussklassen im abitur oder in der
zehn klassen prüfung oder den
hauptschulen ob wir mit diesen maßnahmen
sozusagen unseren spielraum ausschöpfen
oder nicht was ich dann tut das sehen
wir erst in 14 tagen bis drei wochen und
dann werden wir über weitere schritte
beraten je nachdem wie sich die dinge
entwickeln und wir müssen halt auch
genauer werden jetzt noch mal
wiederholen indem nachverfolgen der
infektionsketten und dass deshalb stand
das heute nicht auf der tagesordnung und
deshalb wäre es auch vollkommen
spekulativ sich jetzt dazu zu äußern und
zu einer philosophie noch zu der markus
söder gleich noch etwas sagt mit den
quadratmetern
es geht ja nicht darum dass ein
unternehmen oder ein laden nicht ein
inneres schutzkonzept machen könnte was
uns noch geleitet dass das für das für
den einzelhandel kann das wahrscheinlich
jeder was wir schauen müssen ist dass
wir nicht die gesamte den gesamten
publikumsverkehr in den städten wieder
vollkommen möglich machen weil dann auch
wieder infektionsketten entstehen
sondern dass man das dosiert macht und
da gab es durchaus eine breite
diskussion darüber
und im wege eines kompromisses hat man
sich jetzt auf diese zahl geeinigt aber
die ist nicht wesentlich dadurch kommen
dass man sagt mit 1000 quadratmetern
kann einer kein schutzkonzept machen
sondern sie ist mit der frage verbunden
wie viele läden sind das dann und was
bedeutet dass auch an öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und allein was darum
liegt kann es nochmal ergänzend beide
bereiche
es kommt darauf an unkontrollierte
situationen so weit es geht zu
unterbinden
die menschen haben sich jetzt zu
unglaublich geduldig fallenden
verständnisvoll und zwar auch in
unterschiedlichen millionen mit
unterschiedlicher infektions situation
das war noch mal ein großes kompliment
ist die menschen haben sich da auch
jetzt über ostern glaube ich insgesamt
sehr gut daran gehalten das ist ein sehr
positiver wert wenn wir jetzt her gehen
und überlegen bei ich verstehe dass
gerade login lokal zum essen zu gehen
dass das eigentlich das ist was man gern
machen nicht oder dass er gerne bei uns
hier gerne bier kaufen möchte oder in
andere außengastronomie
wir würden damit aber zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt erheblichste risiken eingehen
man kann in der gastronomie per se schon
keinen mundschutz beispielsweise
organisieren oder dort wo es dann
vielleicht auch die chance gibt der glas
wein oder bier zu nehmen
da wird die disziplin automatisch
welcher darum ist der teil der jenige
der er am entferntesten erstmal ansteht
und ist zweiter bei den acht und in der
tat die bundeskanzlei völlig recht es
gab da etwas unterschiedliche
überlegungen die einen haben gemeint es
ist völlig egal wir machen keine
größenordnung machen dann quasi alles
auch versuchen aber ein schutzkonzept zu
hinterlegen
das problem ist eben einfach dass es
damit zu wahnsinnigen ansammlungen gibt
bei den großen den ganz großen
möbelhäusern den ganz großen
unternehmungen die sicherlich alles tun
würden um zu versuchen das zu
organisieren aber wir führen dazu dass
wir dann in den innenstädten wieder eine
so massive ballung haben dass der ganze
positive effekt der letzten wochen in
wenigen in wenigen tagen sich auf eben
diese und das wollte man nicht riskieren
und darum ist jetzt ein in der tat
kompromiss da gibt es eine baurechtliche
vorschrift wieder als anhaltspunkt kalt
ich persönlich halte 800 auch fast exakt
für zu viel
wir haben deswegen auf englisch die
länder können das machen
ausschöpfen wir haben in bayern
beispielsweise an den kabinetten
überprüfen das war sie auch in der
pinnau dankbar die länder gesagt haben
also in einigen bundesländern ist
weniger an problematik als in anderen
und die die eine stärkere
herausforderung haben müssen natürlich
noch vorsichtig und umsichtig agieren
das wollen wir dann heute nochmal auch
morgen in den jeweiligen
landesregierungen dann haben wir
gewichten aber ich glaube der kompromiss
so ist gut vertretbar
den kann man so umsetzen und ich freue
mich jedenfalls dass insgesamt sich die
vorsichtige der linie
auch die bundeskanzlerin vertreten hat
und die er changer scholz auch mit ganz
entwickelt haben dass die sich ganz
mehrheitlich durchsetzt die nächste
frage herr schmidt vielleicht können wir
das personal ist bei einer frage
belassen im interesse ihrer kollegen
frau bundeskanzlerin anfangs ist es ja
flecken bekämpft das stand über allem
was ist eigentlich die derzeitige
strategie im umgang mit der pandemie
wenn man so darüber schreiben würde also
ist das kipping auf welchem level oder
wollen wir noch weiter gehen alle
neuinfektionen so weit runter fahren
das für die infektionsketten immer
gleich zurückverfolgen können also
worauf läuft es ja gerade eigentlich
hinaus was es da die strategie und
welche kriterien sind entscheidend wenn
es dann um weitere lockerungen gehen
würde na ja also wir sind jetzt in einem
bereich der neuinfektionen
die jetzt in den letzten tagen so um
3000 oder sogar darunter lag die kann
man natürlich in
den vielen gesundheitsämtern durchaus
wenn man wenn die gut ausgestattet sind
nachvollziehen das ist nicht mehr so
dass das überhaupt nicht geht und das
muss auch unser ziel sein
alles andere wird uns in große große
schwierigkeiten bringen das wird auch
vielleicht nicht gleich von der ersten
woche an klappen aber wir werden uns das
jetzt sehr viel genauer anschauen das
infektionsschutzgesetz sagt nicht nur
dass ein gesundheitsamt die zahl der
fälle melden muss sondern ein
gesundheitsamt muss eigentlich melden
sind das menschen in welchem alter an
welcher stelle in welchem ort des
bereits des gesundheitsamtes und wenn
sie dann sehen sie haben einen
infektionsfall in einem altersheim oder
sie haben etwas in einer berufssituation
oder an einer schule dann können sie
natürlich ganz anders vorgehen und auch
die schutzmaßnahmen ganz anders machen
und da müssen wir hinkommen also die
kurve ist flacher geworden ist bleibt
nach wie vor so sie muss so sein dass
sie unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordert und wir haben modell
betrachtungen gemacht wenn wir sind
jetzt ungefähr bei diesem reproduktions
faktor 1 also einer steckt einen an der
natürlich auch nicht das kann ich immer
nur für eine infektionskette sagen ob
eine einen ansteckt und das ist dann ein
mittelwert aber es ist ungefähr einer
steckt ein an
schon wenn wir darauf kommen dass jeder
1,1 menschen ansteckt dann sind wir im
oktober wieder an der leistungsfähigkeit
unseres gesundheitssystems mit den
angenommenen intensivbetten wenn wir 1,2
also jeder steckt 20 prozent mehr 1,2 an
also von fünf menschen steckt einer 2 1
und 4 1
dann kommen wir im juli schon an die
belastungsgrenze unseres
gesundheitssystems bei 1,3 das hört sich
nicht viel wir kommen von 45
ansteckungen drei bis fünf ansteckungen
13 sind wir im juni an der
belastungsgrenze unseres
gesundheitssystems daran sehen sie also
in welch kleinen spielraum wir uns
aufhalten und die ganze entwicklung
basiert darauf dass wir davon ausgehen
dass wir eine infektion zahl haben sie
wir überblicken können die wir
nachverfolgen können und dass wir mehr
schutzkonzepte
und durch die mehr schutzkonzepte auch
mehr lockerungen machen können aber es
ist ein dünnes eis wie hat ja gesagt hat
oder eine fragile situation oder ein
wirklich eine situation in der vorsicht
das geburt ist und nicht über mut ganz
draußen hat idee von wild ich habe eine
frage zu
die meisten gebote söder sprach von
community masken frau bundeskanzlerin
sie sprachen von alters masken sind dass
die masken die die leute tragen sollen
von denen sie noch am vierten april
gesagt haben dass sie zu viren
schleudern werden können und dass man
die nicht tragen soll
und noch eine frage zum nordrhein
westfalen nordrhein westfalen hat
gestern angekündigt dass man auch die
vorschulen unter umständen öffnen will
zieht nordrhein westfalen mit oder macht
nordrhein westfalen am montag schulen
schon auf teilweise und auch die
vorschulen bezüglich der schulen gesagt
worden dass man die letzte klasse der
grundschule gegebenenfalls ab viertem
öffnen kann das mit werden die länder
auch in gewisser abstufung handhaben da
gibt es auch etwas unterschiedliche
meinungen dazu aber das ist eine der
optionen aber nicht sofort und ab montag
sondern sofort bei den entsprechenden
vorbereitungen die abiturklassen die
absolut klasse wieder
ja ich sag ihnen das was wir heute
beschlossen haben und dann gibt es ja
auch die ministerpräsidenten von nrw den
kann man ja auch fragen auf jeden fall
kann ich nur sagen was wir heute
geschlossen haben so zweitens ich habe
darauf hingewiesen und das steht auch
hier glaube ich heute wieder in dem text
dass die behandlung der community masten
sachgerecht zu erfolgen hat das ganz
wichtig sie müssen regelmäßig gewaschen
werden beziehungsweise gebühr
in dem backofen gelegt oder in der
mikrowelle auch wenn sich das etwas
sozusagen aus fröhlich anhört aber was
sind die patentrezepte mit denen man das
wird es halt tschentscher der sensor auf
der an und hat als ich sagen können
ansonsten sind sie nicht produktiv im
sinne des schutzes für andere und sie
müssen auch häufiger gewechselt werden
und das wird eine wichtige aufgabe sein
wir wechseln die seite frau beschrieb
idee ja eine frage frau bundeskanzlerin
sie haben davon gesprochen wir werden
damit leben müssen bis es medikamente
oder eine neben stoff gibt und auch
tschentscher sie haben gesagt das wird
uns über mehrere monate noch begleiten
diese pandemie wenn sie schon jetzt so
weit in die zukunft blicken reden sie
dann auch über konzepte die von manchen
zb dem ort deutschen ethikrat diskutiert
wurden dass man auf längere sicht
besondere schutzkonzepte für fohlen
wohlrabe variable gruppen entwickelt die
ermöglichen dass man anderen nicht wohl
haben mehr freiheiten gibt ist das etwas
worüber sie reden oder ist das für sie
absolut tabu
und ich habe auch noch eine kurze zweite
frage die zielt auf die gottesdienste
wenn die läden öffnen warum ist es dann
unverantwortlich ein gottesdienst
zuzulassen ich habe das gefühl in der
kirche am sonntag sitzen manchmal
weniger leute als an einem
bekleidungsgeschäft unterwegs sind ja
auch die geschäfte werden natürlich
maßnahmen ergreifen müssen das werden
auch die kirchen tun
wir sagen ja auch nicht dass wir reden
jetzt über die zeit bis zum dritten mal
wir wollen mit den kirchen jetzt in ein
gespräch eintreten wie das gemacht
werden kann
die gegebenheiten sind sehr
unterschiedlich zwischen einer kleinen
dorfkirche und einer großen krise wie
dem kölner dom oder
großen kirchen in hamburg vielleicht und
insofern muss das sehr gut abgewogen
werden aber wir haben in unserem
beschlussfassung wenn sie das heute
lesen sehr deutlich zum ausdruck
gebracht dass das wir mit den kirchen
dieses gespräch suchen wollen
und manche länder haben das auch jetzt
schon sehr stark gemacht alle länder
waren mit den kirchen in kontakt und
insofern wissen wir dass wir hier
gemeinsame lösungen finden müssen ihre
frage nach dem langen zeitraum war auch
soja wir sagen ja natürlich für wilde
rabe gruppen insbesondere verpflegen
senioren und behinderteneinrichtungen
müssen nach den lokalen gegebenheiten
gemacht werden wir machen nicht so dass
was ja manchmal diskutiert wird die
jungen kriegen alle freiheiten und die
älteren werden ins abseits gestellt das
halten wir nicht für ethisch vertretbar
aber natürlich müssen gruppen die
anfälliger sind für infektionen mit
besonderen schutz konzepten gedacht
werden wir wollen sie aber gerade nicht
sozial ausschließen das ist hier dass
das nicht zu einer vollständigen soziale
isolation führt das ist unser maßstab
und in dem maßstab muss individuell
gewählt werden
herr rinke der frau bundeskanzlerin ich
würde ganz gerne noch mal nachfragen zur
einheitlichkeit der beschlüsse herr
söder hat ja eben schon angedeutet dass
bayern ein paar beschlüsse etwas später
umsetzt oder in etwas anderer form also
wo fürchten sie werden doch differenzen
auftreten etwa den grenzgebieten weil
natürlich auch ein druck dadurch
entsteht dass bestimmte eu nachbarländer
ganz andere beschlüsse fällen dänemark
und österreich öffnen mehr frankreich
ist verschlossen ist das heute
diskutiert worden
und warum hat man die maske eigentlich
nicht verpflichtend gemacht sie haben
beide jetzt von einem gebot gesprochen
also ich finde es nicht städte wie es
fair gegenüber den anderen journalisten
wenn sie immer zwei drei fragen stellen
das bezieht sich auf die differenz
zwischen den bundesländern und den
kommunen jena hat ja schon ein mehr als
ein gebot sondern einer anordnung ist
dass diskutiert worden dass wir nicht
doch am ende wieder ein flickenteppich
haben wir müssen ja das was wir fordern
von den bürgerinnen und bürgern auch
wirklich umsetzen können und wir sind
schrittweise jetzt mit den community
masken oder alltags massen ja weiter
gegangen das haben sie ja auch erlebt
und in je mehr die vorhanden sein werden
um so mehr wird man vielleicht auch
darüber reden ob es dann noch weitere
schritte der der dringlichkeit gibt aber
jetzt erst einmal sagen wir der solche
maske hat und wer das erhalten kann und
die sind ja jeden tag besser erhältlich
der soll sie auch benutzen dass es also
dass die wirkung des gebots das ist
stärker als das wir das vor ein paar
wochen gemacht haben und jetzt werde man
auch sehen wie die entwicklung dort
weitergeht jetzt habe ich ihre erst auch
so schauen sie gleich kann herr söder
was dazu sagen ich habe noch nicht
gehört dass es zu verwerfungen zwischen
bundesländer jetzt geführt hat weil er
einem baumarkt auf hatte und der andere
nicht
aber es ist vielleicht können dass die
länder mal sagen wie sie das sehen weil
sie das ja auch ich bin mit der
einheitlichkeit zufrieden sie werden in
einem föderalen gebilde nie auf den tag
genau das gleiche haben manche haben
sommerferien im august die können bei
der abiturprüfung noch mal anders
rangehen als der juni mit seinen
sommerferien beginnt aber vom geist von
dem ganzen drangehen haben wir eines
hohes maß an einheitlichkeit erreicht
was für einen föderalen staat schon fast
an ein wunder grenzt nur zwei sätze
gewinnen denn das gewünscht ist also zum
einen weil sie so sehr unterschiedliches
infektionsgeschehen ich persönlich bin
zb ländern die ein sehr geringes
infektionsgeschehen haben oder geringe
sehr dankbar dass sie nahezu alle
maßnahmen genauso mittragen wie den
gebieten die besonders stark betroffen
sind die bayern werden
nordrhein-westfalen beispielsweise das
dann dass der große solidarität herrscht
auch in anderen regionen dass man da
noch mal nach außen anders macht hängt
von der jeweils örtlichen situation ab
das ist dann mal eine woche mehr oder
eine woche weniger oder paar
quadratmeter mehr oder weniger das ist
aber im grunde genommen nicht
entscheiden wir hatten beispielsweise
ausgangs beschränkungen ich
kontaktsperre aber die leute haben sich
an alles gehalten und das bringt ist es
positiv ich glaube dass der föderalismus
sich im moment als sehr leistungsfähig
erweist weil der große vorteil gegenüber
den rein zentralistischen staat ist beim
zentralistischen staat wird zwar schnell
etwas einheitliches verordnet aber für
die umsetzung wird sehr schwer gesagt
wir haben es jetzt geschafft und es sind
zwar manche diskussionen die wir führen
aber die mühe ist es wert wir wägen
dabei auf die argumente untereinander
sehr gut glaube ich kann man sagen
kommen aber doch zu einem sehr guten
text ergebnis und einer umsetzung und
die länder garantieren hat die bessere
umsetzung vor ort weil sie osten her
sind und da das ergibt sich dann
insgesamt aus meiner sicht wesentlich
höhere leistungsfähigkeit das kann man
beispielsweise auch sehr gut an dem
gesundheitssystem erkennen
das ist ja auch sehr föderal organisiert
ist das zeigt sich an der stelle im
vergleich zu vielen anderen ländern doch
als sehr widerstandsfähig nicht geändert
wir haben der erfolg der letzten wochen
gibt uns ja recht wir haben
unterschiedliche wege gefunden den
ländern die rechtsverordnung sind sehr
unterschiedlich von der von der von der
konstruktion aber im ergebnis kommt es
dann doch sehr weitgehend alles aufs
gleiche aufs gleiche hinaus
und wir haben ja in deutschland dadurch
jetzt noch sehr schnell und insgesamt
das infektionsgeschehen verlangsamt also
dass es regionale bisschen
unterschiedlich weil es eben auch
unterschiedliche ausgangssituationen
gehabt aber wenn sie sich mal die daten
des robert-koch-instituts angehen die
dieser faktor die verdoppelung zeiten
wird zu anfang beobachtet haben die sind
eben deutlich in ganz deutschland in
allen ländern zurückgegangen
etwas unterschiedlich was an der
ausgangssituation lag aber im grunde
gibt uns der erfolg der letzten wochen
ja recht dass wir in diesem prinzip
einen einheitlichen maßstab zu haben
über den dann keiner hinausgeht aber den
man durchaus noch strenger ausführen
kann gibt uns im grunde grunde recht und
insofern bin ich sicher dass wir auch
dieses konzept was wir heute entworfen
haben dann weitestgehend einheitlichen
deutschland auch umsetzen können
wir können noch zwei fragen nehmen das
wäre dann herr fried
frau bundeskanzlerin wann kommt die
tracking & tracing ob und warum dauert
das so lange und es würde sportstätten
individualsportarten hier nachbarn in
österreich macht das jetzt für
speerwerfer oder kunst oder so die
sportstätten auf und waren geisterspiele
in der bundesliga ein thema zu dem
zuletzt racing app kann ich folgendes
sagen sie muss ja praktisch vom robert
koch institut für gut befunden seien vom
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik und natürlich auch
von dem datenschutzbeauftragten
dort wird natürlich darauf geachtet dass
insbesondere auch keine anfälligkeit von
bestimmten bausteinen dieser app da ist
und wir müssen auch sicherstellen dass
wir sie anwenden können auf den
verschiedenen sorten von smartphones da
muss man also auch mit den
betriebssystemen herstellern in kontakt
sein
das alles nimmt zeit in anspruch aber es
wird mit hochdruck an den dingen
gearbeitet und sie das erstes wir haben
überlegt und es wurde auch diskutiert ob
man bei sport etwas machen soll
ob man bei kunst und kultureinrichtungen
das machen soll wir haben uns jetzt
entschieden das erst in einem zweiten
schritt beim nächsten mal zu diskutieren
einfach deswegen weil man nicht
vergessen dafür lockern ohnehin an
einigen stellen deutlich wir wollen
jetzt das gesundheitssystem auch nicht
überstrapazieren
wir halten das was jetzt gemacht und
insgesamt für sehr vertretbar
wir haben keine weiteren einschränkungen
beschlossen ist übrigens wichtig auch
noch einmal fest seien keine
einschränkungen sondern einstellen
erleichterungen aber alle die anderen
fragen sowie österreich und andere oder
kultur fragen werden an einem zweiten
schritt entschieden
das gleiche gilt also bundesliga aber
kein thema die liga selber überlegt ja
und arbeitet der sicherheitskonzepte und
wird dann sicherlich das wird sicherlich
daran demnächst ein thema sein darüber
zu reden ob in welcher form
geisterspiele möglich sind das wird man
dann diskutieren kann die letzte frage
von frau kunz frau bundeskanzlerin und
herr ministerpräsident
wieder hat es im kreis der
ministerpräsidenten kollegen gegeben die
vor einer vor einem grossen schaden der
wirtschaft gewarnt haben wenn man jetzt
nicht früher lockert und wann wird die
nächste überprüfung dieser maßnahmen die
sie heute beschlossen haben sein
es war ja schon mal auch von diesem
sonntag die rede das ist da noch meine
zusammenkunft gibt dann ist die nächste
wenn an diesem sonntag gibt es keine
zusammenkunft da laufen die maßnahmen
aus aber wir müssen ja rechtzeitig
vorher die beschlüsse fassen damit dass
dann auch umgesetzt werden kann ich habe
ja erst gesagt wir werden unseren 30 04
wieder treffen im virtuellen raum und
werden dann darüber debattieren was gilt
nach dem dritten mai denn die
allgemeinverfügung oder wie auch immer
die forderung der länder heißen werden
jetzt ja bis zum dritten mai aufgelegt
was jetzt schon absehbar ist dass wir
natürlich immer gucken müssen können wir
eine maßnahme schon in einem 14 tägigen
rhythmus beobachten deshalb ja auch der
14 tägige ansatz also wer sich sozusagen
und da mit einer wenn jetzt die
lockerungen eintreten dann sieht man ja
ob es mehr infektionsgeschehen gibt es
dauert dann eine ganze weile ingo
inkubationszeit dann der test dann dem
mitteilung ans robert koch institut das
heißt sie sehen im grunde erst 10 12
eigentlich 14 tagen hat die maßnahme
etwas bewirkt im blick aufs
infektionsgeschehen war ist alles so
geblieben wie es war
und wir haben jetzt bei den drei wochen
gesehen dass es doch ganz schön
schwerfällig ist bis ich die kurve mal
dann in die richtige richtung bewegt wir
haben es eigentlich sehr schön gesehen
bei dem verdopplung zeiten
wir haben es jetzt in den letzten tagen
gesehen dass wir immer weniger neu
angesteckt hatten als gesunde
das war ja auch eine gute nachricht und
wir können jetzt sind sie jetzt bei
diesem faktor schon in einem bereich den
reproduktions faktor der hat ja auch
immer fehlergrenzen wo man eben auch
sagte da kann man über lockerungen
überhaupt nachdenken und insofern
tritt das also am 30.4 sein bild blickt
auf das was dann ab 4
märz gilt und es gab schon ein großes
gemeinsames gefühl da sind die börsen
bisschen unterschiedlich ich finde das
nicht aber auch in der natur der
verantwortlichkeiten der gegebenheiten
und der sache wenn wir alle gleich wären
dann würden wir sie überhaupt nicht mehr
erfreuen
journalistisch und insofern leben wir
auch von dem hohen gut der
verschiedenartigkeit die uns dann immer
wieder zu kompromissen führt wir haben
auch in der bundesregierung diskutiert
und zum schluss gute kompromisse
gefunden und das ist das was trägt etwas
eine schöne erfahrung ist dank an alle
noch der hinweis wir haben die
beschlüsse also zwei kurze punkt ist
einig welches auch ins laub fraktion die
haben wir zu den schulen ganz kurz wach
sondern zu der frage wer kümmert sich
mehr um wirtschaft und wer weniger eine
frage was man will also wir werden die
nächste woche möglich brauchen damit die
schulen sich vorbereiten können
die lehrerverbände haben ausdrücklich
gebeten nichts überstürzen
das sollten auch unsere lehrer hören das
heißt ab dem 27
können dann prüfungsvorbereitung die
abitur und mittlerer reife ähnliches
stattfinden und wir würden nicht am
schritten sondern 11 mai mit den anderen
abschlussklassen überlegen wie man das
organisieren kann
grundschulen und kitas bleiben dann erst
einmal dazu mit entsprechend
notfallbetreuung aber jetzt sowas zu dem
thema wirtschaft ich kenne keinen
einzigen minister sähen keinen einzigen
und kein mitglied der bundesregierung
das nicht bei dem thema corona genau
zwei herausforderungen kopf hat die
gesundheit und die wirtschaft und da
gibt es niemanden der nicht in gleicher
weise beides absolut als top priorität
einschätzt beides müssen wir im blick
haben der bund hat meiner überzeugung
nach wenn ich das sagen darf ein
exzellentes in europa einmaliges
wirtschaftsprogramm vorgelegt und bei
uns war sogar herr scholz im bayerischen
kabinett was noch nie der fall
war das sein also ein
bundesfinanzminister und schon gleich
gar keiner von der spd da war es war ein
hoch qualifiziertes und hervorragendes
gespräch und nahtlose übereinstimmung
das heißt ich halte jede form von detail
wettbewerb im sinne von wer ist jetzt
der wirtschaftsfreundlichere wer ist
mehr der medizinische in der jetzigen
situation nicht dass er unter uns auch
so seiner für unangebracht jeder tut an
seiner stelle das beste was er kann
jeder will dass die wirtschaft
erfolgreich ist jeder möchte so viel
freiheit wie möglich natürlich aber
jeder weiß auch um die herausforderung
und also gerade wenn ich die mitglieder
der bundesliga an stabilen
internationalen vergleichen oder auch
länder die direkt an der grenze sind wir
können im moment wirklich von ganz
großen glück reden dass es uns nicht
geht wie in den usa
das ist uns nicht geht wie in italien
dass wir nicht schlimme situation haben
in frankreich
und deswegen glaube ich normal jeder
leistet das beste was er kann und da
gibt es mal eine unterschiedliche neos
die es da gibt aber es gibt weder einen
der besser wirtschaft will noch ein der
medizinisches alle wollen das gemeinsame
ziel so dann nur noch der hinweis die
beschlüsse von heute sind inzwischen auf
bundesregierung de eingestellt insofern
können sie manches nachlesen